he's smart and articulate an outspoken
critic of the war in Ukraine and in the
eyes of the authorities An Enemy of the
State
Vladimir caramurza was arrested on
charges of treason and spreading
disinformation
but the 41 year old knew no mercy would
be offered here at his sentencing
his lawyer looked sad but her clients
seemed bemused as the judge said he'd
spend 25 years in prison
a sentence of unprecedented severity
given to a man for speaking his own mind
he says yet another military Adventure
by the unaccountable unelected
authoritarian and frankly increasingly
deranged dictator in a Kremlin by the
name of Vladimir Putin Russians here
Kara Mirza speaks to Sky News just after
Russia launched its invasion
a committed Democrat he was prepared to
criticize the regime at a time when tens
of thousands of Russians had decided to
flee
but the activist who also holds British
nationality was aware of the possible
consequences I think the best thing this
regime would like for us to do
is to give up and run away and we're not
going to give them that pleasure we met
him in 2016 as he entered a slate of
candidates in that Year's parliamentary
election
it wasn't easy at a party event we
sought the security services sneaking
aboard the boat used for the campaign
launch
the following year he was poisoned for
the second time and almost lost his life
he blames the security service
I'm really worried about his health
because
he survived after two attempts of
poisoning and uh his health is weak and
this prison will kill him outside Court
Cara Mercer's lawyer said his Spirit
remains undiminished
when he heard the sentence 25 years he
said I realized I was doing everything
right
the UK's Ambassador said she was shocked
by the sentence
called for his immediate release
basic human rights have evaporated in
Putin's Russia there is no room now to
challenge The Man In Charge John Sparks
Sky News